to everybody else this they look at uh
they see a case and i don't see a case i
see my brother
i see someone that i grew up with who i
slept in the same bed with
who i ate banana mayonnaise sandwiches
with somebody that helped me with my
homework
who i had bible study with who
taught me how to be a professional who
taught me
things about life and
somebody that i can depend on at all
times
he was one of the kind he was one of a
kind i can honestly say that
and what was it like having to watch
some of that horrendous video in court
it was devastating having to relive it
all over again
it's like an emotional roller coaster
stuff is just constantly running through
your mind you have to relive
anything and everything you hear him
constantly
screaming because he's being tortured to
death and he's gasping for air like a
fish out of water
how are you feeling seeing derek chauvin
in court
just he's in there i just hope that
justice gets served and he get convicted
um it's it's not right that
african-american people we never get
justice
we constantly have to worry about
people killing us when we get pulled
over by police officers
it makes my stomach ball because i don't
know
what's going to happen i just don't know
if you're going to get a good cop or
you're going to get a bad cop
police are here to protect us that's
what they're sworn in to do
but at that time my brother
he was killed over a 20-dollar bill
my brother died right there in front of
a store with kids watching him
people pleading trying to render aid and
some of those people
who've given evidence talked about not
only how distressing it was to watch
george suffering but also how guilty
they feel now that they didn't do more
what would you say to them how does that
make you feel um
i wouldn't want them to have any guilt
because
the person who should be feeling guilty
is chauvin
because he killed my brother he had his
knee on my brother's neck
for over nine minutes the thing about it
is
when out there that day you had
individuals out there looking and they
were trying to stop him
also it was a nine-year-old girl and she
was quivering while she was talking
about george being tortured to death
she's going to be shell-shocked she's
going to have that seared in her brain
for years
to come like ptsd and also
you have to think about it she had love
on her shirt
and you think about the other mana she
said
george reminded of her of her father
her uncle her cousin people like that
you have to think about things like that
she would never be able to go through
life again
as a normal person because she would
have flashbacks constantly
of a man being tortured to death and you
go on to the firefighter
she was trying to render aid but they
wouldn't allow her to do it
and when i tell you one thing you better
believe it's a god
because all of those people in one place
at one time
at one time somebody had the video
somebody had love on their shirt you had
a professional
who knew about chokeholds and you also
had a firefighter who knew how to
resuscitate
at that time and what does justice look
like for you
justice for me is a conviction
because murder is not murder until
somebody is convicted of it
and it's too many times that i have seen
people get off
for killing african-american people you
can start all the way back
to rodney king it was a it was
nothing he didn't get convicted he
didn't get any justice
you go to trayvon martin they didn't get
justice for him
you can go on up and you think about
brianna taylor
she didn't get any justice you go to
eric garner he had a video just like
rodney king
he didn't get injustice but right now we
at that lent at that time
we can get justice because people are
marching
all over the world for him and they're
all yelling i can't
breathe and no justice no peace
and how does that make you feel seeing
people around the world
come together behind you it makes me
feel good because people are standing up
for what was right
people marched in a pandemic when colby
was out
putting their lives on the line for what
was right
if people are willing to get out
and put their lives on the line for
somebody else
who they didn't know but they watched
them in the video
and know that he he still should be here
right now
that's a blessing because people
are sick and tired of seeing the same
thing
every time